якщо ми продовжуватимемо те що робимо
зараз підтримуватимемо цей рівень
Україна точно виграє що швидше ми надамо
їм засоби щоб досягти вирішального
результату то швидше це закінчиться Я
вважаю що це може закінчитися що цього
року замість того щоб ламати голову
оскільки часу це займе просто Почніть
посадіть пілотів у кабіну сьогодні щоб
вони могли розпочати навчання не може
бути успішного завершення цього якщо
Росія володіє Кримом
ситуації в Україні наскільки ймовірно що
Росія збирається розпочати новий наступ
і чи готова українська армія стримати
росіян
я насправді вірю що Росія намагається
розпочати новий наступ чи Щось на кшталт
цього вони явно мають більше військ ніж
раніше
Вони здатні почати те що ми технічно
могли б вважати великим насту
у них немає броні техніки можливості
прориву тож Мені здається що це скоріше
збільшення кількості людей які можуть
мати певний обмежений успіх
що змінить загальну оперативну ситуацію
Україна має достатньо щоб обмежити
російський успіх Звичайно це будуть дуже
дорогі людські втрати
боєприпасин
Тобто ви не вважаєте що рішення
відправити німецький та американські
танки було надто пізнім адже очевидно
знадобляться тижні якщо не місяці Поки
вони прибудуть
пізно це зменшує гнучкість щодо того
коли Україна могла б застосувати ці нові
системи але з точки зору загальної
картини ще не пізно
Я не намагаюся підбирати красиві слова
це пізно і ще триватиме ви абсолютно
праві щоб провести тренування і створити
необхідну матеріально-технічну базу
знадобляться тижні але ніколи не пізно
м
президент Зеленський Зеленський закликає
зараз західний Альянс надати винищувачі
як швидко можна було б навчити
українських пілотів керувати ними і
наскільки ймовірно що США та інші країни
НАТО їх передадуть враховуючи Ризик що
Росія може використати це як доказ того
що НАТО безпосередньо бере участь у
бойових діях
кремлівські народи завжди полягало у
тому що все що ми робимо має ризики
ескалації тому що вони хочуть щоб ми
через це хвилювалися я маю на увазі якщо
згадати рік тому так само було з
джавелінами Чи стінгами все Елементарно
вони погрожували усіма видами жахливої
ескалації але нічого не сталося тому що
вони не можуть у них немає нічого іншого
що вони можуть зробити окрім очевидно
ядерної ескалації Яка на мою думку украй
малоймовірно а надати літаки це не
інакше ніж надати хаймерс або панцер
гаубіця 2000 засоби які потрібні
українцям високоточну зброю великої
дальності безпілотники в 16 які
дозволять їм вражати російські авіабази
логістичний об’єкти транспортні мережі і
штаб-квартири це ті засоби які їм
потрібні R16 стали б частиною цього
Тобто ви підтримали відправку
винищувачів f16 в Україну
абсолютно якщо захід продовжуватиме якщо
ми продовжуватимемо те що робимо зараз
підтримуватимемо цей рівень Україна
точно виграє у цьому немає жодних
сумнівів але це може зайняти один
три-п'ять років за цей час буде вбито
багато невинних людей Отже що швидше ми
надамо їм засоби щоб досягти
вирішального результату то швидше це
закінчиться Я вважаю що це може
закінчитися ще Цього року я маю на увазі
що цей рік коли Україна може фактично
перемогти Росію змусити їх залишити Крим
Донбас це буде пізніше тож від нас
залежить як довго це триватиме
намагатися за морозити це не в інтересах
Росії це не опція для України наскільки
це може бути довго чи коротко залежить
від нас
скільки часу займе підготовка
українських солдатів І ще одне питання
чи справді злітно-посадкові смуги
зможуть якось витримувати ці винищувачі
в Україні
усе це розмірковування але жодний з них
не робить неможливим надання цих засобів
пам'ятаєте місяці тому люди переймалися
про те скільки часу знадобиться щоб
навчити українців користуватися
патріотами чи танками
замість того щоб ламати голову скільки
часу це займе просто Почніть посадіть
пілотів у кабіну сьогодні щоб вони могли
розпочати навчання і звичайно Україна
відбере своїх найкращих пілотів які вже
вміють літати що посадити їх на інші
літаки
це не те щоб вони забирали когось із
університету і починали з нуля це не
відбувається у вакуумі необхідно
поєднати це з обстрілами на великі
відстані які вони здійснюють для
придушення протиповітряної оборони
противника Наприклад Україна
дуже чітко дала зрозуміти що вона не
зацікавлена у використанні зброї яку
надає захід для нападу на цілі на
території Росії Вони сказали що не
будуть цього робити Нам це легко
контролювати і зупинити якщо б вони на
це зважилися щодо злітно-посадкових смуг
то це проблема яка цілком вирішується
прем'єр-міністр Великобританії сказав що
він дійсно розглядає можливість
відправки винищувачів чи зміниться
дискурс Сполучених Штатів Німеччини та
інших союзників
Я сподіваюся що так Великобританія
виконала дуже хорошу роботу Я маю на
увазі що вони лідирували у кількох речах
перш за все очевидно з танками
мене не здивує якщо вони і тут будуть
ліберувати звичайно я не знаю наскільки
це з координовано
Я маю на увазі можливо між
великобританією США Німеччиною Парижем і
так далі коли вони ухвалюють рішення щоб
допомогти просувати дискусію вперед тому
я думаю що у Великобританія надає
реальну допомогу
байдуже з координовано це чи просто так
відбувається їхня підтримка та їхній
дуже передовий підхід допомогли тягнути
нас усіх уперед
ніхто В адміністрації байдена чи
міністерстві оборони не зміг відповісти
на це запитання тож я хотіла би запитати
у вас чи є тут червона лінія чого США не
надішлють Україні якими б не були
обставини
єдина червона лінія Очевидно це бойові
частини на території України Хоча я це
розумію Я б хотів щоб президент не
говорив цього більше року тому ви
пам'ятаєте він сказав раніше щодо
початку так званої російської
спеціальної військової операції що не
буде нашої військової присутності зараз
звичайно українці цього не просять їм це
не потрібно кожного разу коли ми
впиралися мовляв Ми не можемо зробити це
або це ми врешті-решт це робили тому я
думаю українці зрозуміли що врешті-решт
ми пройдемо і до наступного рівня
допомоги тому я не хочу говорити що
існує абсолютно червона лінія щодо
якогось певного засобу Я просто хочу щоб
адміністрація сказала що ми хочемо
Перемоги України це те про що вони не
змогли сказати що ми хочемо щоб українці
виграли бо якщо сказати все Тоді вам
треба надавати необхідні засоби а не
дотримуватися цього поступового підходу
Якою може бути перемога і чи було б
повернення Криму її частиною на вашу
думку
Україна чітко дала це зрозуміти Я згоден
з українцями на 100%, що повне
відновлення всієї їхньої суверенної
території є бажаним кінцевим станом
речей мабуть одна з причин чому ця війна
настільки важлива для всіх нас у Європі
та на заході полягає у тому що йдеться
про захист і збереження міжнародного
порядку заснованого на правилах які
включають Статут ООН що визначає
суверенітет нації це частина того що ми
намагаємося зберегти
Якщо нам це не вдасться то скрізь де
Китай чи Росія вважають що спроможні
змінити кордони ми продовжуватимемо мати
справу з цим
це одна річ Але якщо говорити конкретно
про Україну то доки Росія окуповує Крим
вона лише перечекає поки ми втратимо
інтерес а через два-три роки зможе знову
атакувати з Криму як рік тому і можливо
навіть важливіше те що Україна ніколи не
зможе відно не економіку поки Росія
сидить у Криму і може блокувати доступ
до Азовського моря де раніше Україна
мала два найбільші порти Маріуполь і
Бердянськ
звісно Одеса до якої всього 300
кілометрів 100 кораблів завантажених
зерном стоять в Одеському Порту і
чекають поки російської інспектор
перевірить що це лише зерно Я знаю що це
результат угоди Але Росія змогла зробити
це лише завдяки своєму чорноморському
флоту який базується в Севастополі
тому не може бути успішного завершення
цього якщо Росія володіє Кримом
хоча на заході схильні говорити що весь
світ воює разом з Україною це неправда
Як ми знаємо є такі країни як Китай
Бразилія є Індія зрештою є Туреччина чи
вважаєте ви Що єс приміром має чинити
більший тиск на Туреччину щоб вона
обрала одну сторону
ви абсолютно праві що на весь світ
залучений Я думаю що Індія Китай
очевидно Іран активно підтримують війну
Туреччина зробила більше хорошого ніж
поганого і своїм контролем над протоками
блокуванням входу та виходу російських
військових кораблів а також наданням
реальної допомоги
Я вважаю що насправді було б корисно
якби є тиснув на Туреччину щоб вона
більше допомагала та на інші країни в
регіоні але це також і відповідальність
Сполучених Штатів нас ніколи не було
стратегічного підходу до чорноморського
регіону ми говоримо про Грузію ніби це
острів про Україну як про острів про
Туреччину як про острів замість того щоб
відступити на крок від карти помістити
Чорне море посередині карти і тоді Це
змінить ваше уявлення про регіон
Я вважаю що Сполучені Штати та наші
союзники повинні мати довгостроковий
стратегічний підхід до чорноморського
регіонування
відносин із нашим союзником по НАТО
Туреччиною
а також дало людям у Грузії більше
впевненості що вони не залишиться у
підвішеному стані Грузія відчуває
величезний тиск з боку Росії партія яка
перебуває при владі грузинська мрія
відверто кажучи не принесла жодної
користі вони прикували себе наручниками
до трупа Кремля і тому я вважаю що
Сполучені Штати та інші мають ухвалити
довгостроковий стратегічний підхід до
цього регіону який включатиме дипломатію
та економічні інвестиції а не лише
військові
президент Зеленський зараз бореться з
корупцією у своєму уряді що станеться
якщо він не дай боже буде поранений або
навіть вбитий і не зможе може керувати
своєю Україною країною наразі найкраще
навченою та оснащеною армією у Європі чи
варто розглядати такий сценарій
те що він запустив у дію матиме не лише
позитивний ефект у боротьбі з корупцією
ми допоможе українцям розвинути почуття
національної ідентичності яке вони
завжди мали українці завжди мали почуття
культурної самобутності
знали що вони не росіяни не хтось інший
що вони
українцічності мені здається що вони
зараз досягли іншого рівня і
усвідомлюють що їхнє майбутнє залежить
від Західної інтеграції що означає
дотримання стандартів Європейського
Союзу дотримання стандартів НАТО Я думаю
що всі ми можемо і будемо колись якось
Я не знаю Хто буде наступним на черзі
при владі у Києві Але я думаю що є
багато справді талановитих жінок і
чоловіків які могли б зайняти цю посаду
якщо буде необхідно
цієї дуже цікавої розмови я хотіла б
попросити вас озвучити найкращий і
найгірший сценарій для України
у Захід у втратить бажання підтримувати
на що Звісно сподівається Кремль що ми
скажемо ми просто більше не можемо цього
робити
А це типова ситуація це був би найгірший
сценарій тому що тоді б Росія була
винагороджена за свої тисячі воєнних
злочинів їхню агресію порушення
міжнародного права порушення
суверенітету тоді звісно китайці
побачать що ми не є дієздатними найкращі
сценарії це коли захід скаже що Україна
повинна перемогти Давайте дамо їм те що
їм потрібно зокрема високоточну зброю
великою дальності щоб вони могли
звільнити Крим і я вважаю що якби це
було забезпечено вони могли б звільнити
Крим до кінця цього літа до кінця серпня
Дякую У мене дуже дякую До побачення